que tenemos aquí tenemos 3 elevado a la
potencia
y esto será igual a la raíz quinta de 3
al cuadrado entonces debemos resolver
este misterio quien es a poner pausa el
vídeo puedes intentarlo observa que sí
que si tienes ninguna raíz quinta algo
que tal vez se te ocurra hacer para
deshacer esta raíz quinta es elevarlo a
la quinta potencia pero claro si bien le
bases a la quinta potencia también debes
debes elevar el otro lado de la ecuación
a la quinta potencia para que se
mantenga la igualdad en la ecuación
entonces hagamos eso vamos a elevar
ambos miembros de la ecuación a la
quinta potencia y el lado izquierdo de
la de la ecuación aquí debemos recordar
las las propiedades de los exponentes
tenemos entonces que 3 elevado a la
potencia y eso elevado a la quinta
potencia es lo mismo que 3 a la a por 3
a la a por 3 a la a por 3 a la x 3 a
lara
y esta que es igual esto será igual a 3
elevado a la a más a más a más a más a
donde esto es igual a 3 elevado a las 5
por la potencia así que la propiedad de
los exponentes aquí nos dice que si yo
elevó una base a un exponente y eso lo
elevó a otro exponente es equivalente a
elevar la base al exponente que es el
producto de estos dos exponentes por lo
tanto esto lo puedo escribir de la
siguiente manera 3 elevado a la potencia
5 por a 5 por a y esto será igual si yo
tengo la raíz quinta am y la elevó a la
quinta potencia solo te va a quedar lo
que tienes en el radical entonces esto
es igual a 3 al cuadrado y ya queda un
poco más claro esto es cierto entonces 3
elevado a la 5 por ar debe ser igual
debe ser igual a 3 al cuadrado otra
manera de pensar en esto tenemos la
misma base entonces este exponente debe
ser igual a este exponente
así ya podemos escribir que 5 x
debe ser igual a 2 y resolvemos esto
entonces podemos dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre 5 nos queda entonces
que a es igual a dos quintos 2 sobre 5 y
este es un resultado interesante porque
lo lindo de este ejemplo es que nos
motiva a ver cómo definimos los
exponentes fraccionarios cierto así que
vamos a sustituir esa a que acabamos de
encontrar ya sabemos la respuesta
resolvimos para entonces tenemos 3
elevado a la dos quintos lo cual voy a
poner en color en colores para que quede
un poco más interesante en 3 elevado a
la potencia de dos quintos esto es igual
esto es igual a la raíz quinta ahora
nota que la raíz quinta aquí el
denominador es la raíz
y entonces es igual a la raíz quinta de
tres al cuadrado tres elevado al
cuadrado
así que si tomas esta base el 3 y lo
eleva al cuadrado
pero después tomas la raíz quinta de eso
eso es lo mismo que elevarlo a la
potencia de dos quintos entonces no te
lo tomas este 3 lo eleva al cuadrado y
tomas la raíz quinta de eso o podríamos
usar esta propiedad esto esto se puede
escribir como como 3 al cuadrado esto es
lo mismo que 3 al cuadrado y eso lo
elevas a la potencia un quinto esto
elevado a un quinto vimos esa propiedad
acá arriba cierto puedes multiplicar
estos dos exponentes y obtienes dos
quintos y eso es lo mismo que 3 al
cuadrado y tomar la raíz quinta de eso
acá también lo tenemos 3 al cuadrado y
tomas la raíz quinta de eso